hello everyone this here is truly an
amazing game between Bobby Fischer and
the Hungarian Grandmaster Paul Benko the
game was played it was the United States
Championship from December 1963 to
January 1964 and well Bobby won the
previous five United States Championship
that he competed in and well this is the
sixth United States Championship he
competes in and well he won he won the
entire event with a perfect score of 11
wins out of 11 games and it was a very
strong tournament three previous winners
of the US Championship also competed
similar similar reshef ski Arthur bigger
and well Larry Evans and well the game
is very interesting as at one point
Bobby Fischer well out of six moves he
plays five moves with his Queen and one
move with his King it's very interesting
and also he plays one one amazing rook
move that that's just out of this world
so but okay as usual I'll let you be the
judge of that
Fischer is white and the Bangko is black
we have E 4 and G 6 the modern defense
but it will transpose into the into the
purse defense D for Bishop to g7 we have
Knight to c3 d6 f4 and 9th to f6 and
then we here we have the purse defense
with white playing f4 we have Knight to
f3 Benko castles and Bishop to d3 by
Fischer Bishop to g4 is played and ok
this Bishop to g4 is a bit isn't really
the best move maybe Knight to c6 was
better this is a practically forcing h3
and then well white will have to capture
the night if he doesn't want to go back
with the Bishop which Fischer place we
have h3 Bishop captures on f3 Queen
captures and now Knight to c6 I'm going
for that d4 pawn Bishop to e3 is played
and the well here White has everything
ready and the white is ready to put a 5
himself so if black wants to get any
counter play he will have to push he 5
himself but this well this leaves white
better as you'll see so we have E 5
favorite plays D captures
five we have D captors on e5 and our
Fisher place at five a very nice move as
this prepares a very strong attack now
Fisher is threatening g4 and g5
so of course Benko plays G captures on
f5 we have Queen captures on f5 and well
although it seems natural to capture
with this pawn this would actually favor
black because if he captures an f5 then
Benko has this resource of playing efore
sacrifice upon sacrifice but he will get
he will get some counter play after
white captures and rook e8 for example
so after this G captures on a5 Fisher
plays correctly Queen captures on f5 and
we have night to d4 with an attack on
the Queen Queen to f2 is played we have
night to e8 and we have castles by
Fisher Knight to d6 now we have Queen to
G to be kink the h8 Benko is on painting
and we have Queen to g4 adding even more
support to this f5 square and we have c6
by Polanco and now Fischer plays Queen
to h5 and this was a Fisher's idea all
along and well this has already moved 17
and well for the entire game so far
Banquo was unable to play f5 so now he
now he plays Queen to e8 and now he's
ready to push f5 but Fischer doesn't
allow this he plays Bishop captures on
d4 we had he captures on d4 and now the
brilliant move I mentioned earlier in
the intro official place of rook to f6
and this is completely crushing this is
well there is no there's really not a
good good move black can play here
well what's the idea the idea is 'if
I've and well the threat of checkmate MH
7 of course you can't even capture Dirk
if you capture the rookie 5 is coming
you can't really defend checkmate on h7
so here banco try that King to g8 with
the idea well after face replace e5 he
will push h6 now there is no Queen
captures on hl7 checkmate but Fischer
just plays one
really simple move and Banco resigns the
game official place Knights Knight to e2
he gets his Knight out of harm's way and
wall bank was knight on d6 is still
attacked and in this position appalled
Banquo resigned as there is no move he
can play if he moves the knight for
example Knight to be 5
he had screen to f5 now threatening
checkmate on h7 this is undefendable and
if after Knight to e2
well it's the same if Bishop captures
for example on f6 Queen captures on h6
and now again this Bishop on f6 is
blocking this f7 pawn and queen to h7 is
well there's no defense you can prolong
it maybe 90 for Bishop captures but
there is no more move to play Queen h7
is coming so yeah after 92 banker
resigned the game and well we have this
brilliant victory by Fischer a brilliant
miniature in this is move 21 and this
rook to have 6 move it's it's well it's
beautiful the whole idea is and I mean
blacks entire plan for this game was to
push f5 and Fisher found a brilliant way
a way to refute this f5 idea so yeah
Fischer won this is his sixth win for
the United States Championship he wanted
with 11 out of 11 points and Larry Evans
was actually second and they
congratulated Larry Evans for winning
this tournament because while Fischer
wanted with 11 out of 11 and Larry Evans
who was second had 7 and a half out of
11 so it was well it was really in a
different league they said that Larry
Evans actually won the tournament and
that Fischer just opened the exhibition
to show that he is far far superior to
everyone else so yeah I do hope you
enjoyed this game and the rook move and
well everything Fischer brought to this
tournament and I would like to thank
Tony more guitar and Dean wells for a
contribution to my channel thanks a lot
I really appreciate it as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
y'all for watching guys and I will see
you soon